هناك تطورات عاجله في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
وبتحديد في القدس مواجهات في الاقصى بين
الفلسطينيين وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
التي اقتحمت باحات المسجد الاقصى
كما تصل هذه الانباء متتابعه وتتحدث عن
اقتحامات الان مجددا استعدادا لمنع اعتكاف
المصلين في المسجد القبلي هذه الليله معنا
من جبل الزيتون في القدس مراسل الجزيره
الياس الياس كرام هل لكان تصف لنا الوضع
غايه في التوتر جمال وقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي اقتحمت باحات المسجد الاقصى
المبارك قبل انتهاء صلاه التراويح وبعداد
كبيره وهي تحاصر الان الابواب المؤديه الى
المسجد القبلي هي قامت قبل دقائق معدوده
بقمع المصلين وهم بالالاف في داخل المسجد
الاقصى المبارك بواسطه
الرصاص المطاطي وهي تحاول ان تدفعهم حاليا
للخروج خارج الباحات لكن عمليه الاقتحام
جمال تمت بالفعل قبل انتهاء صلاه التراويح
وهذا يدلل على ان قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي كانت تبيت هذا العدوان المجدد
على المسجد الاقصى المبارك من قبل وهي
كانت تسعى من وراء ذلك الى اغلاق المسجد
القبلي والى اغلاقي قبه الصخره المشرفه في
هذه الساعه تحديدا مع انتهاء صلاه
التراويح لمنع اي عمليه اعتكاف قد تتم على
غرار ما حدث
فجره هذا اليوم الذي سينتهي لكن يبدو انه
يوم طويل جمال يوم مشهود من المواجهه من
ايام المواجهه في المسجد الاقصى المبارك
وفي القدس عموما هذا يدلل على ان المدينه
وعلى ان المسجد الاقصى المبارك هم جوهر
الصراع بالفعل وهم ايضا ما يوحد
الفلسطينيين في كل مكان وجودهم جمال اذا
نحن نتحدث عن قمع لقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي
للمتظاهرين او للمصلين في داخل المسجد
الاقصى المبارك قبل انتهاء الصلاه وكان
الجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي كان يخطط لهذه
الخطوه منذ ساعات حيث ايضا منع دخول بعض
الشبان الى داخل باحات المسجد الاقصى
المبارك لاداء الصلاه
لاداء صلاه التراويح وكنا نشاهد في بعض
مقاطع الفيديو التي تصلنا تباعا بان ق
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي كانت تمنع الشبان من
الدخول الى داخل المسجد الاقصى المبارك
لاداء صلاه التراويح واداء صلاه العشاء
الان الخطه تتجه نحو افراغ المسجد الاقصى
كليا من اي فلسطينيه متواجد فيه نحن نتحدث
عن نحو 20,000 مصللا تمكنوا هذه الليله من
بلوغ المسجد الاقصى المبارك واداء صلاه
الترويح هذا عدد منخفض
تماما عن العدد الذي شارك في اداء الصلاه
يوم امس حيث كان العدد وفق تقديراتي دائره
الاوقاف الاسلاميه يصل نحو 80 الفا لكن
اجراءات الاحتلال كما يبدو ايضا بروده
الطقس والاوضاع المتوتره في المسجد الاقصى
المبارك هذا اليوم ربما ادت الى انخفاض
هذا اعداد المصلين الى 20000 فقط مع ان
الايام الماضيه كان المسجد الاقصى عامرا
بشكل كبير بالمصلين كما